biodiversity is the variety of all life
on earth this astonishing web of living
things cleans our water we drink
purifies the air we breathe keep the
climate in balance pollinates and
fertilizes our crops
[Music]
biodiversity with life job opportunities
peace and stability but we're losing
nature like never before
habitat loss over exploitation climate
change pollution and invasive alien
species are the five drivers of
biodiversity loss the new EU
biodiversity strategy 2030 is our global
commitment to tackle the root causes of
biodiversity loss the European Union
will lead by example and boost our Green
Deal diplomacy
our international trade agreements
emphasised biodiversity protection that
will fight wildlife trafficking
who will step up cooperation with
partner countries and increase finance
and sustainable and nature based
solutions the European Union is setting
an ambitious worldwide agenda the stop
biodiversity lost globally
we are taking action are you
[Music]
you